bounds eight assists and three steals
yes um can you take me through the block
well you know just a hassle play
um i thought i'm gonna get dunked on to
be honest with you but um you know
going down the stretch just do whatever
you know it takes to
win the game you know just put yourself
in a position that
can be the game and you know uh you know
so so you know i saw the play coming no
i'm so that uh chris chris paul was
throwing the lab
so i just i'm just gonna jump vertical
you know towards the rim hopefully i can
you know be there in time and uh
i was there in time and was able to get
a good black and uh go down
uh get to a point so so i was a
great hospital uh it felt like a strange
angle like
it was one of those spots where the the
toss just kind of came out of nowhere
did it surprise you at all no no
it didn't surprise me like i saw it
coming like i knew once i see
saw him putting on the his one hand
he was too far for a layup so i knew he
was throwing the lab and i committed so
much
uh and you kind of like heuristic you're
gonna feel it you i felt him like
rolling into the ring behind me so i i
know the only chance to
get a stop is just jump towards um
towards the rim and try to cover that uh
that angle for him to score and aiden is
so strong
you so you legitimately thought as you
went up he was gonna he's gonna dunk it
yeah i was late like usually i play like
that
it's a if i was in the upper opposite
side it's it's a dunk
you know but uh as i said
like i didn't jump to plug the ball i
jump
towards the rim that i feel like that's
what uh kind of helped me
put me in position to uh get the block
because i jumped
the rim was right here so i jumped right
here
so he could like shoot the ball if he
shot the ball to the
backboard he'd probably be a goaltending
you know but he tried to dunk it
so i was right there earlier than him